I got to ask you when did you discover
boxing what when did you first fall in
love with
boxing when it saved
me how did it save you I I was I was a
stupid violent kid that was angry not
exactly know why he was angry uh I'd fit
in real good in today's society because
there's a lot of angry kids out there
that I don't think they know why they're
angry I was I was just out there getting
fights and um I got this stupid thing
from that can you tell the story of how
you got that I was just running around
doing stupid things bad things I heard
people some people physically but I
heard I heard my my my
family you know that's BS you only hurt
yourself you know that that's a good way
of you know Alibi in
it um you know to but if at some point
the truth usually Finds Its way I'd like
it to look like it was just hurt myself
but it wasn't obviously so I was just
out on the streets with kids that didn't
grow up in the neighborhood I grew up I
grew up in a neighborhood where father
was a doctor and um I walked down the
street the funny thing was down down the
hill was a very tough neighborhood
called Stapleton and most of the people
down there on the corners wish they
could get up there and I I wish could
get down the hill so I went down the
hill and I hung out with all these
friends that became lifelong
friends and
uh I um I gravitated to that because I I
figured out later a little bit but you
know I wanted family we were disjointed
family we were you know my father was a
doctor he didn't have time for nothing
but being a doctor you know uh I think
when you gred something you sacrific
something too
you know when you're really great at
something so great that maybe God Made
You great and and you're too great for
your own good and and I don't know it
took me to these
stupid dangerous places dangerous for me
but dangerous for other people too
because I got to the point where I was
doing robberies on the street I was I
was fighting everybody and and you know
what the most dangerous part about it
was and I came to this realization on my
own all by myself I I figured out um I
was really really as D you know these
kids from the project some they got
nothing M you first of all I learned you
don't have to be poor to be
poor you don't have to be deprived of
certain things to be
deprived and or because you at least to
think you're deprived and I was pouring
away that I didn't have the only thing I
wanted to have him so here
I here I am where I'm out there doing
these things and what made me more I was
more dang than some of these Psychopaths
well I was a psychopath too I guess the
way I was behaving but some of these
Psychopaths that really had
nothing um you know really would you
know they obviously would kill you I I
was dangerous in the almost in the same
way but for a different reason I know
it's ridiculous what I'm about to tell
you but i f get it
out cuz I felt it I thought I was on a
righteous path I thought I had a
right because it was going to get me my
father
back why why I mean you know you're
scientist you couldn't figure this one
out
because all the people that had them
were injured people fractured people
screwed up people in some ways but but
hurt damaged people
so if I get
damaged I'll get
him so I was on a
crusade really a righteous Crusade where
I thought it was okay I had permission I
had permission to do these terrible
things quite frankly and to fight
everyone and do I I did and then it it
came almost to a
crash doing all that you know winding up
in Reicher Island like an
idiot not understanding the damage I did
to this poor man that you know he um he
was a great doctor and he's got to see
his son and hear about you know what I
mean
like
God I I was out on that day you know
with with the guys that I grew up with
now you know the guys from the projects
from the as I described and I was with
one of them who he he's dead now so I
was I was with him and we
were we we were in a neighborhood the
neighborhood we grew up that that I hung
out and and they and he grew up in Billy
he came from the from the project and we
got into a thing where we cut somebody
cut us off we cut them off you know
jumped out to
fight and um you know it turned out
there's like five or six of them and two
of us and
um you know we fought you right on the
side right there only about a block from
where I used to hang out and um maybe
block and a half and right in front of
like a Spanish Bodega and uh it really
does happen in slow motion I actually
saw the guy I was fighting the guys that
that I had to fight and then all of a
sudden I was able to get one guy out of
the way a little bit and um I really I
noticed the guy go into his pocket and
um I knew why was going in his pocket
you know
and when he came out of his pocket I
knew what it was right away it was weird
because in the neighborhood guys used to
hang out they were they were into this
you know they get into feds like right
on the streets and they went to at that
time they went to this cheap knife but
it was they thought it was we thought it
was cool uh it was A7 and and um and the
cool thing whatever was that you could
flick it you could learn and I learned
how to flick you know but I never
carried a knife but but when my friends
would have it I would just you learn how
you could flick it open not a
switchblade but flick it with your wrist
and I was like here I am in the middle
of this freaking fight and all of a
sudden oh it's A7 you know and and and
so I'm like I you got to make a decision
you know
and I got to splits I can either not do
nothing which wasn't didn't seem like a
great you
know a great option um I couldn't run
away what
up because you got to live with yourself
afterwards and and and that's more
difficult to live with than whatever it
is at that second because that don't go
away you couldn't live with yourself
running away it just don't go away that
thing not none to do with being brave
yeah it nothing to do with being brave
really it it's got to do with just
common sense in life that for for
me whatever you're dealing with it's
over it's done like like okay deal with
go to bed whatever but you you do that
you know that other thing you you you're
gone
um you you that never that never ends
this thing ends memory of you being
let's say a coward in that moment that
never ends the only thing I had at that
point in my life in my stupid mind
was a reputation yeah that I would do
stand up to certain things that that was
like and that for me was was worth
something whatever because I didn't feel
any Worth to anything else that was the
only thing I felt a connection of wor to
so so stood your ground I say no I made
a decision yes I stood my ground but I I
actually things do slow down they do and
I actually said it's A7 he's got a f you
know I didn't say but he's got to flick
it I got a split second either like I
said either I do nothing whatever or I
get to him before he gets it flicked I
went to get to it before he got flicked
and and I and I just as I got close to
him I I did him a favor I I I walked
right into a counter
punch because I I I cooperated with him
I went right to him and and just as I he
he
he he practiced more than I did with
the7 apparently because he was like bo
bo bo and
and anyway what did you think what did
you think that happened that was all
slow motion did you think he might
die yeah well not immediately took me a
minute I'm a slow learner I put my hand
up right wouldn't you I guess so mhm and
it went into my face yeah and that was
it it was gooey it was warm and gooey
and I was
like I don't know I I don't know what
this means but I don't want to know but
I think I know and
and and
um did you think about your dad in that
moment no you know what I thought about
him was
um you know you don't know who anyone is
into to DET test it and um I learned
that cuz used to tell me but I learned
it uh he say you I remember one time C I
was a 17 18 year old kid up there and
you know thought I was whatever I
thought I was and he said you got a lot
of friends and um I said yeah because
you know I was on the street hanging out
with a 100 kids at night sometimes on
the street corner so I was like I didn't
know too many people that hung out with
100 Kids on the street
on a corner on a Friday satday night and
um I was like yeah I got a lot of
friends he go
really really he said
um how about if I told you you might not
have any most likely you don't have any
and he
goes and then he just started this thing
he said everyone's got to be tested
you me everyone cuz you don't know about
nobody to they test it he goes you know
nothing he goes you know nothing until
you know until something happens to test
if they were really a friend and then he
told me this story about a guy a guy
came to him and he was upset what are
you upset about he goes I'm upset
because I I I just uh I just lost a
friend uh you know after 20 years of
friendship we're not friends no more so
Co looks at him he goes
let me ask you a question what what made
you think you ever friends with him now
the guy gets insulted it goes did you
hear me he goes I I just told you 20
years I've been friends with this guy
why would you say that to me he said
well I say it again what makes you think
he was your friend he
goes whatever happened in the 20 years
other than chasing girls because figured
that one out fast chasing girls and
drinking together
um and whatever else you're doing out on
the street whatever gave you the
inclination that he was a friend yeah he
goes whatever when did he risk himself
to be your friend yeah when was it
dangerous to be your friend when was the
Friendship tested when was it
uncomfortable to be your friend and you
know what the guy said you can figure it
out you're a scientist he
said he said today yeah and and and
today came for me and today today today
today kept coming for me today and and
that day my friend Billy it turned out
while I was fighting these whatever five
six guys and where was Billy he was on a
roof he was on the roof he was on a roof
he was my best
friend and um
so anyway they take me to the hospital
and here's the thing with my father but
one thing Billy did do for me when he
got off the roof thank God he did he he
dragged me dragged me into this Bodega
laid me on the floor and started putting
towels right and the towels I vaguely
remember this they filled up with blood
yeah I mean completely like drenched
like like you put them under a shower
and and um I Heard the bod owner
screaming screaming you know like you
know whatever and everyone's screaming
and there chaos and I'm like I don't
know I'm I'm
calm weird I'm like real
calm and
um I'm just in this
place's
calm and all of a sudden I hear Billy
he's screaming call the call the
ambulance call the you know and nobody's
doing nothing everyone's Frozen I'm
starting to understand already people
get Frozen in situations people the fear
fear fear fear fear just paralyzes
people and um and I was going into a
fear business I was learning I was learn
I was getting a a learning early PhD
yeah and all of a sudden genius Billy
genius really Street kid yeah he jumps
up on a freaking counter jumps over the
counter grabs the phone calls 911 says
the cop's been shot yeah and forget
about it yeah it was crazy all I
remember after that I'll tell you the
couple things I remember
lights being put onto a stretcher
bounced around you know rushed
I felt everyone's
anxiety except mine I had none but I
felt everyone's anxiety everyone's fear
like was all around me it was like wow
this is interesting this kind of I know
that's stupid but like w this is
interesting wow you really have an eye
for fear that's fascinating you're
really studying it well they I had no
choice I I got introduced in the crash
course and they they put me in ambulance
and this is what I remember to your
point I'm sorry I took so long to get to
it I am although I'll probably do it
again before this conversation's over
but I the journey yeah we'll get there
we'll get there pops um so I I hear the
cops say I we might lose them and I'm
like laughing to myself I'm not laughing
because I'm not again I'm not John Wayne
John Wayne would have laughed but I'm
like
lose you guys are stupid you know I
didn't say that but I'm like lose me I
my father's the greatest doctor in the
freaking world yeah there's not no worry
about you people all you people are all
uptight and whacked out here with with
fear and and there's nothing to worry
about Dr alas is my father so anyway so
they're they're they're taking me to the
and they said we don't have time I hear
a couple things I remember don't have
time take them to they take me to the US
public health hospital Marine hospital
was called at the time but US public
health and it's in Stapleton so it's
close thank God so they're taking me and
I hear them on the radio you know saying
this stuff about we got to we got to
move we got to move and
um I start
talking and they're tell me don't
talk but I like to talk a lot you know
and I'm
so again fear there's no fear when the
fear's been
removed it's the only time you're really
free in life and I know that sounds
absurd but really it is it's the only
time you really free in life I was when
you're close to death when you're devoid
of of of things that that normally hold
you back that normally influence you in
ways that that you know that are not of
the influence that always positive
influence where you're where you're in a
pure place where you're you're in a
purely free place from all inhibitions
from fear from anxiety from from Joy Joy
can screw you up and you're free from
all these things and I'm in this place
just in the back of an ambulance you're
free I'm yeah I'm I'm like I said just
give me Dr Atlas and they say we don't
have time no no no no no you don't you
have to get Dr Atlas you have to get him
this was the damn it this was the you
know what I mean I finally freaking hit
the number and I'm not getting paid and
then all of a sudden I'm out how many
they well I think it was 400 200 inside
200 outside or whatever it was a lot hey
look after after after 50 it's the
number doesn't matter no more right or
whatever 60 70 80 90 whatever you know
so I was fortunate I was fortunate and
of course they I was fortunate they told
me afterwards it miss my juggler
literally by like like a centimeter I
mean whatever and um so then um then we
wouldn't be having this conversation
obviously I'm glad you made it yeah
that's another I'm kind of glad too and
and it just missed my eye which thank
God it's fair enough I have a scar
matching me with a patch I
mean I mean it's enough that I get this
freaking
thing and um and look look it goes all
the way you know I mean it's you know
it's it's pretty long and
um I don't know I was out and then
somehow I sensed like they had the
curtain closed you know and it's amazing
how Vivid this
is and the curtains Clos and I see a
shadow I I felt the presence I did and I
felt him he's a he's a powerful guy and
I felt him
and I just see like a shadow you know
and all of a sudden uh the the curtain
gets pushed back and I can't really see
it's dark and I'm you know out of it but
not completely out of it and um pushes
the curtain back comes
in and his hand even though it's all
bandag you know whatever but his hand
surveys it felt
safe and um it felt it felt warm and
safe I was happy and um he got there you
know did he say something yeah yeah
remember I gave you a little bit of
introduction to my father right you know
him now a little bit right yeah yeah
what did he say about the job he said he
just said this is what he said I
remember to this day what he said yeah
that that I do remember I don't know if
it was six or five people but this I do
remember yeah he said they did a good
job you're going to have a scar the rest
of your
life any he
left